the kind of work that Professor Johnson
is doing is very cutting edge and we are
very very lucky to have her support of
our intellectual professor Johnson and
you have a request if you can I try to
not move around too much height because
we're also okay I'll try to restrain
myself I know I'm going to date myself
but I came to the Harlem project for
that very personal reasons I actually
was a columbia college undergraduate
here Wow many many moons ago and I think
I have a very particular remembrance of
New York City in the 1980s I actually
lived in I think it's stalled still
called East Campus we overlooked
morningside park and in the 1980s Harlem
was dark Harlem was basically owned by
the city and was depopulated Central
Harlem was essentially be populated and
what population remained was it was an
interesting mix I mean there was still
the sort of old Harlem that sort of
settled brownstone neighborhoods of near
convent Avenue near city city college
strivers row but central harm the part
that Columbia basically sort of
overlooks really was just incredibly
devastated and my remembrance and I'm
not sure if I really want this recorded
but I guess it'll end up being recorded
anyway was of seeing and hearing
helicopters going over morningside park
with the lights on if you ever have a
chance to see a movie called new jack
city I don't know if you talked about in
class or we'll talk about it
okay well it really captures in many
ways what it was like to live in New
York City in the 1980s and really in
some ways what was going on in Harlem in
the 1980s especially in the crackhead
demak really just completely devastated
Harlem as in addition to other
neighborhoods of color and I just would
actually add that the apartment building
that they used in New York jack cities
now luxury apartment building that I
definitely couldn't afford on my salary
so you know just tells you how things
have changed in about 20 odd years so on
going with this sort of devastation or
these periodic proclamations at Harlem
was back you know New York magazine
which you know has many issues I've many
issues with New York Magazine blur on
things they like to do is talk about
real estate never once in a while they'd
say oh you know Harlem is back
everyone's Bryan brownstones its back
and it never really came back to the
sense of being repopulated with diverse
neighborhoods with stronger retail
better public services I don't think
that really happened until probably the
mid to late 1990s well this is happening
I also briefly worked for a Community
Development Corporation and one of the
things that we were doing is we were
trying to build a senior house I'm sorry
a building for seniors basically the
only federal money left for low-income
housing essentially is senior housing
that even that might be gone by now but
that really was one of the few streams
of funding left at that point for
funding public housing so we're trying
to fund this building and get the
funding in place and get the site put in
place and all these sorts of things and
again and again it would turn out that
well we couldn't quite get this site or
we couldn't quite get approval on the
funding because of HUD see and I was
sort of puzzled you know why was it that
here we are we're trying to do something
great for the community but this other
community group was blocking our path
why is that and you know eventually I
think we sort of
drew on our board of directors and we
sort of got whatever permission that we
needed in formal permission that we
needed from each EDC and the end the
building rapport and it's occupied and
it's a great project so I kind of put
that on the back burner and when I came
back to Barnard at least basically hg DC
was under investigation Cuomo had left
office Pataki governor Pataki who was
the governor before Spitzer launched an
investigation into hu DC and essentially
shut it down and I should say that his
investigation was not the first
investigation HUD see had to
periodically been investigated by the
city of New York as well as the state of
New York from the basically from the
early 1970s onwards and and that was
another puzzle then how was it that an
organization that seemed to block other
organizations from doing anything in the
neighborhood and had also been the
subject of periodic scathing
investigative reports and to my mind
really had done nothing because
essentially Harlem essentially stood
unchanged and in fact kind of got worse
from the 1970s to 1980s how did this
happen how how how did this happen where
did this organization come from how is
it able to mass so much political power
and yet not use that political power for
the common good so that sort of was my
personal path towards this project and
that leads in that led to a question
about Community Development
Corporation's in general that is the
question of what is community
development who who is it for what
community how do you define that
community for what purpose should we
engage in community what do you mean by
the word development do you mean housing
development doing economic development
what kind of economic development give
mean retail d mean manufacturing I mean
you can sort of parse every word and it
really gets very complicated and I think
in terms of my evaluation it commune
Development Corp
missions that's kind of what I conclude
is that it's not really clear what we
mean people come to it with very
different approaches very different
understandings and I think that makes
the job of community belt meant and can
we develop ment corporations what I'll
call CDC's even more difficult even
complicating that even more is the
question of Harlem itself that is is
Harlem indeed still the capital black
America and then if we say that or if
you agree that it's the capital black
America for what blacks Latinos blacks
were Latino descent upper class blacks
poor blacks middle-class blacks I mean
again the whole question of what do we
mean by community and in Harlem I think
that really became a significant and has
been continues to be a significant issue
so what I want to do is kind of try to
start with a kind of an overview of the
sort of the background of commune
development corporation CDC's and then
move into a little bit more about the
history of HUD see some of the
observations that I have one of the
things i should say in it i don't think
it really has come out in the article
it's kind of awkward to say this but
people are very defensive people who are
associated with HUD see are very
defensive and i can understand why
because it had a huge mandate to develop
harlem and they felt that they were
constrained by so many things lack of
funding lack of support whether at the
federal level the state level or the
city level expectations that really
exceeded their the reality so i think
they're very defensive about it at the
same time i think that all organizations
especially organizations that purport to
represent communities should be held to
some level of accountability so you know
some of the things i'll tell you
basically have been told to me off the
record people just don't really want to
talk about it and the other thing is
that because i'm not quite sure where it
stands now but at the point where i
interviewed people it actually was still
technically considered an ongoing
investigation
so people really literally didn't want
to speak on the record because they
could have been subpoenaed so that kind
of gives you background of kind of the
politics of hud see at least when I did
the initial research in around two
thousand okay so what are the goals of a
CDC well William tab who is actually
great economist has some really
interesting work pieces but I'll go on
from that basically gave for sort of
goals for CDC's and one was a CDC should
expand economic and educational
opportunities through the purchase and
management of properties and business
businesses second CDC should improve the
health safety and living conditions
through CDC sponsored health centers
housing projects and so on third CDC's
should enhance personal dignity and
independence the expansion of
opportunities for meaningful
decision-making and self-determination
and forth CD CDC's profits should be
used to pay a community this quote
community dividend rather than the
return to stockholders so again you can
sort of take each goal and sort of say
well that's a huge goal in and of itself
I mean to create housing project I mean
that's I mean I having worked on that I
mean that's a multi-year project a
health center I mean that's you know
taking on the US healthcare system I
mean it really is a really ambitious and
so what I think I would argue is that
basically CDC's were basically put in a
virtually impossible position from the
very beginning that is they were
expected to deliver so much when the
reality given the structural conditions
was very limited the second thing I
really want I hope you can take from for
my for my talk is again the notion of
participation I talked about
accountability but there's also the
element of participation again who is
that community and how does that
community community get involved in
developing or shaping that community and
what I found in my case studies is that
CDC governance is not necessarily by the
people it
by the staff by virtue of the staff
orientation and commitment so the people
that interviewed at hgtc felt that even
though they may or may not have lived in
Harlem they were working for Harlem
based organization and so therefore they
represented the the needs and desires of
the community but it's one step removed
and so again we have to ask yourself
well is that really the kind of a
participation that we should use to
evaluate and to use as a means of
community other issue of grassroots
involvement or non-involvement I think
again what has happened continuously and
still continues to be an issue today is
a feeling among many longtime Harlem
residents that commune development is
something that happens to them it's not
something that they actually engage in
that somehow projects are announced
things happen and then they have to sort
of react so they really I think the
feeling is that while community
development organizations are supposed
to allow for a more proactive stance
towards the development of a community I
think most ordinary residents feel that
they have no sort of say in what even
commune development organizations do so
I think that is an issue and then
there's the question of ultimate
accountability if we think about it in
sort of a political science kind of way
for a legislature the ultimate sanction
or means of accountability is an
election but for a CDC who's funding
might come from the state from the
federal government from foundations from
the city it's not really clear who or
what can hold that foundation
accountable and again I think that's
something that I saw not only in hg DC
as sort of a worst-case scenario but
even in bed-stuy corporation and other
organizations that that I'm working on
with and with another co-author we're
actually working on a much broader
project looking at sort of first wave
can be Development Corporation's over
time and trying to understand what
happened with these organizations from
their inception in the late 1960s tilt
it all right so even complicating this
question of accountability and end
participation was its intersection at a
very interesting particular moment of
time of black power that is what black
power came a really interesting mix of
of rhetoric as well as ideology for the
people who kind of came to prominence of
black power advocates who came to
prominence during during the 1960's it
simply it was a it was not only a means
of controlling land it was actually
means of controlling the development of
the community it was a means of develop
controlling what went on in the
community so it really was once it's an
oppositional force that is was us
against them against the downtown
interest against the sort of people who
were seen as exploiting Harlem with that
came very and then this is a very
interesting what you sort of uncover one
of the things was on the Foundation's
part this fascination with black power
it really it's just it's kind of it's
interesting it's very interesting to
foundations at that point in time this
really seemed like this source of
authenticity that is Wow here are these
people who are demanding power this is
great one of the stories I heard about
Franklin Thomas who was the head of
bed-stuy restoration Corporation and
then later became the head of longtime
head of the Ford Foundation and one of
the memos they kept talking about how
tall he was and would it big afro he had
I mean it really and not just once but a
couple of times like why are they so
fascinated by his big afro so there was
sort of interesting thing about the way
the Foundation's themselves really saw
black power is this sort of authentic
expression of community interesting
community
power coupled with that was through the
gender politics of black power itself
that is there were many who saw black
power as a reassertion in a way of black
patriarchy the patriarchal systems so
there was a real sense that women were
playing too large of a role in
developing in these community
development organizations and I just
want to quote one observation this was
about Brooklyn but I've seen other
similar kinds of observations in another
cities around this time and it says this
go look at the neighborhood boards in yo
and model cities programs they are
dominated by women and preachers you
can't get the working age men to take
the program seriously the failure to
involve men the working or unemployed
fathers has been the single most
important failure of the poverty program
but economic development is different
business is man's work it promises power
and status they come out for that so you
know it's kind of mind-blowing to read
something like that and I think it
really again sort of complicates this
picture of commune development
organizations I think we tend to think
of organizations as sort of being these
kind of empty vessels these sort of very
sort of work a day kind of organizations
that kind of just do things and in fact
organizations come with a lot of baggage
they're developed they're created within
a particular political and social
context and so again that's what I
really want to emphasize about Community
Development Corporation's in general and
particularly about HUD see is that it
really comes out of a particular moment
in time and place and I think for that
reason alone you're the evaluation of
how HUD HUD see performed is can be
somewhat tempered I mean I don't think
we can be totally negative about it some
about its performance okay so
there are a couple sources when we think
about the about the sort about the
origins of cdc's one was clearly from
the community I think one of the things
that basically happened by the
mid-to-late 1960s was the sort of
exasperation with these studies it was
study session I mean he just you know do
any search and Cleo and I mean the
amount of studies done in the 1960s on
the ghetto and their urban crisis it's
just mind-boggling and kind of sad to
think that there really is not that kind
of level attention paid to cities and
urban problems now nonetheless there was
this real sense among residents of
inner-city communities that you know
enough is enough we've had enough
studies please no more and I think these
are such great quotes wondering one you
know again endless community community
meeting one of the one of the one of the
participants said you know please no
more studies were sick and tired of
studies we just can't really have any
more studies enough of it so I think
certainly that was one source the second
source was essentially urban and rust
the federal government politicians felt
that we had to do something or they had
to do something about this urban unrest
so they created or they enacted the
special impact program SI p which was
really a means of giving more power to
local groups to engage in community
development second source was political
entrepreneurship that is politicians
like Robert Kennedy as well as Nelson
Rockefeller we're looking for ways to
kind of buff up their liberal
credentials and and advance within the
Democratic Party and that also advanced
to national office
ok so in 1964 then Nelson Rockefeller
has this vision of gaining higher office
and he basically would within a sort of
very complicated space of new york state
and city ethnic and racial politics
comes to a deal with Harlem's urban
leaders that is in exchange for locating
a facility and Harlem day which they
would give their support to his to his
campaign and so really Rockefellers
working with sort of those from his
established Harlem political elite and
they come to agreement they decided to
put this office building and everything
seems to be great and then suddenly
black power kind of emerges in the
cities and this really i think shakes
the new the the older harlem political
elite and certainly shakes rockefeller
it's really interesting going through
his his archives and seeing the memos
that they're writing or what's going on
what i thought we had a deal suddenly
they're protesting what are they
protesting about we're giving them a
building what else do they want so it's
it's really very interesting to sort of
see his side i mean they really had no
idea why are these people protesting
they thought everyone was happy so and
this is where you really see the direct
rhetoric of black power that they really
see not just an office building they
really see it as a means of creating a
community development center that is a
place for housing product or housing a
place with daycare facilities a place
for creating small businesses so really
a very different vision of Harlem then
the traditional Harlem politicians were
willing to accept what is interesting
against or the role of political
entrepreneurship to politicians who are
now who are young then but are now older
now Charlie Rangel and H kala McCall
appear on the scene and they're sort of
the go-betweens they kind of negotiate
between these black act local local
grassroots black activists
and the Rockefeller Harlem political
establishment now what they decide is
though the in addition to the state
office building which is by the way a
really terrible bad piece of
architecture and I wanted to bring a
picture of it to show you how bad and
how bad it was but you've seen it so you
know was understanding that was reached
with the state and that's the HUD see at
the same time that black power and
service this controversy over over
political and community control is
emerging there was another sort of surge
of riots and and this was in this was a
response to Martin Luther King's death
and this was another sort of oh we need
to do something for the cities and
relates was seen as a tribute to dr.
King so Rockefellers response was the
creation of an urban development
corporation something that would really
work throughout the state and help to
redevelop the weaker areas of the state
inner inner city areas of the state an
agreement that they're reached with the
community and again this is not very
clear I mean if you can actually
literally look at the memorandum
memorandum of understanding and you see
the community in quotes but it's not
really clear who the community is and
they have a bunch of different
signatures but again the question of who
are these people and why are they the
ones to be signing this contract
essentially with the state setting up
this new organization and rockefeller
essentially gets his wish he goes
becomes the vice president and HUD C
becomes kind of a semi-autonomous a part
of the UDC the UDC runs into a number of
problems ironically it's it's the source
of basically the fiscal crisis New York
State in new york city's fiscal crisis
of the 1970s so it's sort of an irony
that the organization that was supposed
to rescue the city's ends up in fact
making the city's worse
the city's worse so it essentially leads
the city and the state towards
bankruptcy and all of the attention is
really being paid towards failing the
EDC out of its problems and the HUD see
essentially kind of de facto left on its
own and this is really where you kind of
see the politicians take over take over
HUD see and this is not to say that
during this time ACDC wasn't doing
anything I mean it's in some ways
heartbreaking to look at the early
studies that they developed because they
really had this really interesting
really broad-based vision of
redeveloping Harlem probably not
something that we would really kind of
agree with today because it was very
much an urbanist version a modernist
version of development and not the sort
of small scale neighborhood type of
development that that most architects
and planners would endorse today but you
know they really had a really
significant vision of what could be done
for Harlem whereas they're developing
these these programs another blow comes
and this is basically next thing gets
elected and he becomes the first of many
Republican presidents who essentially
say you know enough with this city stuff
and turns off starts begins the first of
many cutbacks in urban spending so
essentially a CDC sort of left to drift
that there's no really oversight at the
state level there's really no oversight
in terms of federal programs and federal
funding because that released kind of
disappeared and they're kind of left to
kind of make their own way figure out
what what are they supposed to do and
this very very difficult situation and
in fact one of the things I talked about
and what you know it's sort of out there
and I think I really a number of
interesting studies have been done is
the plan shrinkage of New York City this
was something i think it was first kind
of floated by roger star who died a
couple years ago which was the sense
that
you know New York City and other big
cities had gotten too big they were sort
of obsolete and so really what needed to
be done was that cities needed to shrink
and the best way to shrink cities was to
withdraw services if you withdrew
services you could get people to move
out of those areas you can kind of
basically have an orderly shutdown of
cities now you hear this today and
you're thinking well that's not quite
right and it's not quite right there's
actually a great book called a plague on
your houses can't remember the author
but they talk about the impact of this
plan shrinkage and one of the things
that they argue is that it in fact
helped make the AIDS epidemic even worse
because it so decimated public services
that when this epidemic hit it really it
was able to spread so HUD see again is
in this very very difficult position
because it's not even getting support
from the city in fact the city wants
areas like Harlem Coney Island bed-stuy
to kind of in essence kind of disappear
at least consolidate so again and again
HDC is still producing these plans and
still sort of showing them around but
you know no there are no takers really
and there's sort of limping along and
they come upon this idea which is the
Harlem International Trade Center and
this was really attractive from I think
an emotional viewpoint the sense that
not only was Harlem the capital black
America but really in some ways who is
the mecca for Africans across the world
the African Diaspora and so they thought
if they had this International Trade
Center they could attract more
businesses certainly businesses that
would be interested in maintaining or
strengthening a link link with Harlem
and with the African American community
and I think by this time there was a
realization I think among not only
people in Harlem but in other inner-city
areas that any manufacturing that it
existed in the cities essentially were
coming back and this really kind of
takes out one of the sort of goals of
CDC's a lot of CDC's were created
especially in Midwest industrial areas
to bring back manufacturing
and it simply wasn't going to happen for
a variety of reasons cost space the
nature of manufacturing itself had
changed and you know if they weren't
going to locate in the u.s. I mean they
were going to locate in China or in
Mexico or over I mean wherever costs
labor costs and and other costs for
lower so what you get is ben is a slow
organizational drift on the part of HUD
see again i think that there was
attempts to sort of turn the
organization around but really there
really was no way to i mean there was
really very little that HUD see could do
during the late 1970s and 1980s there
really wasn't anything that it could do
and one of the reasons why i couldn't do
anything obviously was money but
secondly the city controlled the land
most property most of the empty
properties that were in harlem the
brownstones especially were were owned
by the city of new york and the city of
New York really had no plan essentially
other than boarding them up and
periodically putting out fires that were
set by carcinus I think I need to wrap
it up soon right I'm doing fine what
happens in the crack epidemic after the
deep
well what happens and that's a good
question is that I think one of the
things to Mayor Koch is credit is that
he realizes that the sort of drift of
the city especially if Harlem simply
couldn't go forward that it was in many
ways this huge untapped potential
secondly because of the crack epidemic
because of the gentrification in other
areas people who had lived say in SROs
in Midtown even the upper west side were
essentially being pushed out so there's
a huge homeless issue and suddenly oh my
gosh we've got to house these people so
where were worse housing whereas their
housing well it turns out Harlem so the
first really grand city plan that
emerges really emerges as a result of
this realization that you know we need
to put these people somewhere and in
fact there were attempts to send them to
other cities like to newark new jersey
and new york civil you know we have our
own problems why are you sending us more
poor people so i think it was this
realization among the Koch
administration that something needs to
be done and I think near there are
people within the Koch administration
who said you know this is something that
you know we could obviously make money
on zai means I think certainly the real
estate industry the people who tend to
be long term players really knew and
understood that you know New York City
possibly was coming back and if New York
City was going to come back the next big
frontier in terms of access to downtown
would be Harlem because if it's subway
connections and because of its housing
stock outside of some areas of Brooklyn
I mean really Harlem was the last area
that had this sort of density of
brownstones of really nice potentially
nice brownstones as well as vacant land
so
HUD see though you know one of the
things that happens with HUD see and I
think one of the things that we have to
be aware of in terms of these
organizations is the question of
leadership there's the question of
accountability but then also the
question of well if there's no
accountability then there's no way to
sort of evaluate leadership and
sometimes quite frankly organizations
need new leaders and in the business
world well what happens your stock price
goes goes down the CEO or the president
gets forced out in an educational
institution like Columbia you know the
president stops bringing in grant money
or he stops bringing in donations and so
we need a new president it wasn't really
clear how you could get new leadership
or new blood into HUD see so it had a
long time director in fact basically
what he had essentially one director the
early director had been pushed out and
the board was a sort of a kind of a
weird board it had a mix of permanent
members and then it had politicians so
the politicians would usually send
designate someone in their office to
stand in their stead so there really
wasn't a kind of continuity of control
over in terms of the board of directors
and so there really wasn't a way to kind
of say okay times are changing HUD see
you need to be a little bit more nimble
you need to sort of realize that hmm
people are getting interested in Harlem
you need to maybe stop thinking about
you know the Harlem International Trade
Center or stop thinking about Harlem on
the Hudson which was this fast kind of
casino development hotel complex it
really was a very interesting one but
not quite realistic and really sort of
focus on you know developing brownstones
are pretty putting together mortgage
pools or something like that which is
something that bed-stuy restoration
corporation had actually been fairly
successful in doing so basically I think
H EDC is sort of kind of plugging along
and by this time other people and other
voices are emerging in Harlem so in some
ways it's or the breakup of the sort of
traditional Harlem
Elite that is there are other people who
have come up come to sort of prominence
through other means certainly through
the sort of social sort of the social
policy world the foundation world and
they have their own organizations
backing them so there really is sort of
more energy Ford Foundation has
developed a couple of different
organizations that really were involving
it started to get become more involved
in community development during the late
1980s and 1990s and HUD see I think for
a variety of reasons didn't quite
realize that that it was shifting that
the terrain was shifting and I think
what was also shifting in terms of in
terms of what was happening in Harlem
was that it was I think the shifting had
turned away from the notion that you
would have one large monolithic
organization sort of controlling
development on place towards a vision
that was in some ways more pluralistic
that is you'd have lots of different
organizations competing for funding
which can be good and bad but it would
lead to more flexibility more
responsiveness so I think that was part
of what was happening in the foundation
world as a whole the policy world during
the 19th especially during the 1990s the
sense that you know large organizations
aren't necessarily the best kinds of
organizations for redeveloping reap
developing areas inner city areas so
given that what happens then is that HG
DC is kind of existing in its own world
and I think periodically their attempts
to kind of talk to the leadership and
try to get them to do other things but
for a variety of reasons you know cogs
vil i think the the leader of the
executive director is really kind of
resistant and HUD C becomes really
firmly aligned with in the minds of many
people with wrinkle and with the sort of
black Democratic caucus and so when
Pataki governor Pataki a Republican is
elected he really goes after all of his
enemies
goes after HC DC in particular and I
think you know it wasn't just Pataki I
think a lot of the sort of journalists
who covered new york city new york city
politics had really heard a lot about hg
DC and it's sort of lack of ability to
get things done and in fact it's kind of
obstructionist obstructionist tactics
trying to block the activities and the
development of the development work of
other organizations so he goes after hu
DC and he essentially is able to shut it
down and it's unfortunate that it
happened the way that it did because one
of the things that HUD see did was they
essentially got rid of a lot of their
records so the history of HGD
unfortunately is very fragmented because
i think it just kind of people said well
it's done we're over were done and they
kind of walked away so it was so
unfortunately it wasn't quite an orderly
shutdown I think it just I think people
just sort of felt like you know they
were under attack and that was it so
what does this all mean I think that
what it means in terms of thinking about
development in Harlem is that it very
much and has always been a contested
question about who exactly should be
control of shippy controlling Harlem one
of the things that happens when HUD is
shut down is another organization is
created and this one really has kind of
the combined backing of the foundation
world city and state government they put
in Deborah right who was also had been
head of the empowerment zone if I
believe correctly correctly enterprise
there you go and and she really has this
extraordinary support and you know I've
been sort of in thinking about this this
this this lecture I've been trying to
tease out what you know was it her was
at the times it could have been anyone
that it was just sort of the right time
for Harlem to develop the way that it
did or was it simply that people were
just resistant to the notion of
a community development organization
that was explicitly designed to be under
the control of the community and it's
it's hard to tell I think it's partially
both I think that um there was a real
resistance on the part of those outside
of Harlem to really kind of be
comfortable working with an organization
that really had such a strong stance in
terms of community control I think that
the organization itself didn't help its
own didn't help itself by its it's sort
of lack of focus and it's sort of
lethargy sort of it got older and got
sort of lethargic so I think that you
know ACDC was put in a very very
difficult position and I think that one
of the sort of questions to ask you know
if in fact they had been given the types
of the type of support that the new
organizations have been given would they
have developed Harlem in the same way
and you know I have to say that I'm not
really sure I think there's been a lot
of criticisms of Harlem's kurland
current development that it really is
relied more on national chains that
there really hasn't been a lot of
attention to the development of local
businesses who you know would contribute
to the capital base of Harlem and you
know given not only the what's facing
not only Harlem but other inner-city
areas i'm not really sure if that kind
of vision of economic development that
rests on small local businesses really
is possibly a viable one for the 21st
century i think it's a nice idea but i'm
not really sure is it really ultimately
could have been done so i think that you
know when I look at Community
Development Corporation's when I look at
Harlem I see lots of competing interests
and competing values i think there's the
notion that these organisms that the
organization should serve the people who
have lived there the longest i mean
there are people who have lived through
lot a lot
Harlem they've lived through you know
the fires and the arson and the crack
epidemic and they really have stayed
when others have left and now some of
them have stayed because they really had
no other place to go but others have
stayed because they really believed that
Harlem was a special place and not to be
preserved and protected so the court for
them a question of who Harlem is for and
what Harlem should be should it be
simply another version of fourteenth
Street should it just be another sort of
strip of national chain stores or should
it be sort of a small community or an
organic community where people know each
other and you know your neighbors or
should it be just simply a transient
area where people kind of come and go
and it's sort of anonymous large
apartment buildings and I think in some
ways Harlem was very lucky there are
other organizations that we've looked at
in st. Louis in Newark New Jersey which
is you know I haven't had this kind of
development however it has turned out
that Harlem has experienced so I don't
want to run it down but again you know
if you have a vision of urban life as
being something more than chain stores
I'm not really sure that the Harlem
development has really approached that
on the other hand certainly it's much
better than it was in the 1980s I think
for the people who continue to live
there on the people who have now lived
there it's a great vibrant community
it's it's got lots of things going on
and I think there really is a sense that
it's arrived so after all these sort of
perhaps possibly you know to
proclamations at Harlem has arrived I
think truly it has arrived the question
is the role of commune developments now
and in the future in terms of shaping
house development thank you
we had a few minutes for some questions
yes see that article mentions that
weekend in Monster apart he talks about
mr. rangel percy sorry mmhmm yeah oh I
didn't mention the Suttons okay yeah
yeah weekend months it was sort of our
kind of structure this course in terms
of community development in a bit of a
beer but in order for you also mentioned
at four others especially ambitious
clauses in the intro opportunity
does your cortical sort of mirror was
what was suggested in
well I think there are two things one of
the things is that first of all I
shouldn't say calm Charlie
representative Rangel has a very
interesting political career because he
actually defeats adam clayton powell who
in some ways it's kind of interesting
how kind of career is kind of parallel
each other so he actually defeats powell
and seen as a sort of big fresh breath
of fresh air palos eNOS is kind of out
of control guy and Powell in and wrangle
comes in and kind of says okay I'm gonna
you know represent Harlem I'm going to
really advocate I'm not going to go on
my cruise boat and hang out with pretty
women like you know Adam Clayton Powell
so but given that so that's Rangel I
mean Rangel I think sees this as an
opportunity to sort of make his mark and
kind of differentiate himself from the
Harlem kind of I mean now they're all I
think very close but I think at that
point in time he was seen as this sort
of newcomer and they weren't quite sure
about him I think the other thing about
that in Europe I mean there's been a
couple of New York articles and your
magazine has essentially been I'm I in
my opinion has always been fairly
hostile to David Dinkins if you I mean
if this is a great research project that
really go back and look at the media
coverage of Dinkins and I'm from day one
completely negative I mean just they had
nothing nothing nothing good to say
about David Dinkins so I think in many
ways this was kind of that article was a
reflection of this kind of you know
these guys who we don't really like
because they really don't see themselves
as having to sort of kowtow to City Hall
that they see themselves as really kind
of separate from and not beholden to the
sort of city establishment so I think
that's that's part of what's happening
in that in that article that said I mean
I think Percy Sutton and wrangle and
Dinkins have been and probably still are
very politically powerful
and they think they really shaped a lot
of what kind of went on in Harlem
especially you know during the 70's and
80's it does that answer your question
okay do I consider them being
obstructionist I think that I'm being
filmed so mm-hmm I mean I think that you
know certainly they have their own
business interests but i think they
simply weren't willing to I mean I think
it's an issue of turf that they saw
Harlem as their turf and why should they
sort of say okay you want to do this
shurfine whatever so yeah that could be
construed as obstructionist and
certainly from the point of view of the
small development organization that I
worked for you know certainly having to
get their approval you know that was
definitely not great but on the other
hand I think they did see themselves as
kind of you know this is our turf just
as the other politicians in other areas
of the city would say possibly the same
thing so
okay yeah Churchill
given
this position of the 18 filled with the
HDFC as opposed to HT bc housing
development on corporations yeah another
yeah and the current situation in HDFC's
where it's the same low accountability
and regions and what is done the changes
in all vulnerable coop owners
specifically how do you split the
financer why on the well that's I think
that's really it's an interesting
question in fact that's kind of a
separate article and it's a separate
issue which i think people haven't
really thought about is that basically
when federal funding essentially shut
off the state at some point steps in
start to offering money but really
there's not a lot of money and so what
happens in the late eighteen nineteen
eighties 1990s is this notion of
leveraging let's leverage money so you
have organizations like the New York
City partnership you have an
organization called Liske low income
support corporation I think that's what
it is I could be I could be wrong and
there's actually another there's a
provision in the tax code where you can
actually sell some sort of a bond in
order to raise money for housing and so
what happens is that creating housing
becomes basically financing housing
becomes incredibly incredibly complex I
cannot tell you how complex it is
basically you might have four or five or
six different kinds of funding stream
coming in just to create a 10-unit
building I mean if you thi want to talk
about inefficiencies and that's
inefficient to have ten different or
five different funding streams come in
for a 10 or 20 unit building the amount
of paperwork that you have to do the
amount of due diligence you have to do
it's just it's it's it it's not it's not
efficient I don't think it's quite
rational but that it was and I think
still is the reality is that you know
foundations went through this phase
where they will really want to know
organizations to show that they were
entrepreneurial and nimble and they
could go out and raise money so what you
have been is that the scramble to bring
together money and then you also a
scramble to produce housing because you
know it's bad now but I mean you had a
serious serious homeless problem
starting in the 1980s with
gentrification and you know the
continuing basically decay of housing
decay and abandonment of housing and so
all these groups are scrambling to
provide housing and hfd sees in some
ways are kind of you know little kind of
almost like holding companies if you
will to sort of put together the
financing packages for housing and
sometimes they were used for buildings
that were renovated and then people
would be put in or these were actually
buildings where people lived in and then
they sort of use this H of DC structure
as a means of financing the
rehabilitation of the building but I
think in some ways it was very
short-sighted that it was you know this
is the best way to sort of get the to
get the funding together and to get the
housing developed and I think also I
think you know not only for for all
sorts of things in the community
development world is that maybe I think
people think you know this is housing
this is a great bang and everyone's
going to act nicely and so I think
they're built with the best of
intentions they assume that people will
run them with the best of intentions but
unfortunately the world isn't like that
people don't necessarily act with the
best of intentions and I think this is
one of the tensions of these as though
you know one of the organizations that I
looked at as another organization called
banana Kelly in the Bronx and one of the
things that they quickly came to the
realization was that at the end of the
day essentially their landlords
and if someone doesn't pay their rent
they've got to kick him out which kind
of defeats the whole purpose of
developing low income housing zuv people
who don't have homes have a place to
live so you know it's CDC's are they're
really just caught in this incredibly
awkward position where they're supposed
to be you know saviors of the
neighborhood you put on the other hand
you know houses and buildings don't heat
themselves you know you're not doing a
favor to the other people in the
building by letting people not pay the
rent because you're not gonna have
enough money to pay for the housing to
pay for the heating bill and then the
city comes in and says well you know
gotta vacate the house got to vacate the
building you know it's not up to code
and then you're right back where you
started yes this is absolutely
fascinating and I would love to keep you
here for three hours but we can't do it
because we have any hesitations but
since I'm the professor in the class of
how privileged myself and asked the last
two questions okay the first is about of
your interpretation of neoliberalism and
what happened in the 90s mhm to the
early 21st century just a comment my
sense is the shift in Pataki is is not
so much a shift to a Republican regime
because Rockefeller was a Republican
okay um and in this state in this city
you've had historically this weird
relationship where Republicans were
actually throughout most of the 20th
century the Liberal Party and the
Democrats because of Tammany and was a
conservative court mm-hmm that isn't
true in the United States but it was
true in New York oh and the most literal
mirrors New York has had have been
Republicans basically and one thinks
about it laguardia Oh Lindsay right now
Republicans hey hey hey um what happened
in the 90s was a shift from Keynesian
bourbon management to neoliberalism and
privatization right and that Debbie
right represented Oh a black face on
that process and the reason that she's
been so successful the argument that
many people make who are critical of
privatization is that there is a shift
from allocating resources through the
state to enhance civic out comes to
having basically a private model and
that's how come you get to chain stores
and that's how come you have essentially
a realist rate driven model because what
it's about is privatization and so that
the development of Harlem using a
neoliberal model means that poor people
will lose out in the process and things
get more expensive and center Ella is a
great place to shop but not too many
poor people can afford to buy the week
they're right or election there are
second injuries all right so just what
is your take on I'm your liberal that's
the first time second thing is
Columbia's version of development is
manhattanville in the expansion of the
University from one hundred and twenty
fifth Street 130 third Street what's
your take on that does that benefit the
development of West Arlen mm-hmm okay
first one heel liberalism foo and three
words for less well I think that you're
right i might think that what happened
is essentially a notion that there i
think there really was it's a
trickle-down effect of the government is
bad and nothing that government does can
in any way be good so not only is
funding cut off but this notion that you
know you know anything that government
does really is dysfunctional I mean at
the same time that you're seeing this
cut and funding you're seeing I think
it's somewhat warranted critiques of say
public housing you know public housing
at least the way that some of these
projects were built were completely
dysfunctional
and so I think what happens is that it's
this deal agility legitimization of any
kind of public role that it's simply
it's just going to be bad you know
you're just going to see bad outcomes I
think the other thing is you know a kind
of a privatization of Social space of
public space I mean at the same time
you're having government say that we are
not obligated to provide housing for
people unless it's under court order you
also have the development of Business
Improvement Districts who hire their own
security guards who hire their own
sanitation crews you have also the
development of gated communities I mean
essentially you know this is not just
New York City it's happening across the
nation where there's really this notion
that there is a constraining shared
public space and there I know whether or
not there ought to be I think there is
and that government really shouldn't
play a role and supporting whatever
public space there is and that if you
can't afford your own private space well
that's too bad it's the efficiency of
the market so is this kind of markets
are great markets a fabulous but you
know people make markets and I think
that's what people advocates of free
markets don't realize that people make
markets they don't just sort of
magically arise so that's my
neoliberalism answer my second Columbia
answer I should preface it saying that I
don't have tenure so I'll be diplomatic
I just some would be very clear I don't
have to write it you know I think part
of me feels like well certainly they've
learned from the past in many ways that
it's not a replay of 1968 I mean there
certainly went into it very gingerly
although you know secretly because their
investor just like any other investor in
any other investor Trump or whoever
would have done the same thing that very
quietly acquired properties or rights to
property that's kind of what you do
if they in fact had said oh we're going
to expand it wouldn't have gone beyond
that we're going to expand the second
issue is whether or not it's a good
thing well or is it a good thing for
West Harlem I think given what's
happening with the rest of Harlem my my
sense if it is that I'm I always sort of
wondered why those didn't become bluffs
essentially why didn't manhattanville
essentially become another soho it's got
a great space it has kind of the cobbled
streets its next 125th street it's on
the water and well now I know it never
became as though because in fact
Columbia was buying it up so I think if
Columbia wasn't doing it the private
market would have done it I don't think
you know given the state of development
of Community Supported development that
you know whatever happened there would
have been fragmented that you know
community organizations may have been
able to get one or two buildings here or
there but in terms of controlling
development in that area they it hasn't
been it hasn't shown up in other areas
of Harlem that it's really been very
much a market driven development so
unfortunately I think that's what's
happening in Harlem in general so
whether it was Columbia a trump or liffe
rack or whoever I mean someone was going
to come in and get that given the
absence of a will and political power on
the part of people of Harlem to control
their own destiny
all right now we have been you've been
really great and I have to cut it
because we have presentations all right
I understand